manifestation hier à belgrade des
milliers de personnes en colère se sont
rassemblés devant le parlement dans la
capitale serbe les forces de l'ordre ont
fait usage de gaz lacrymogènes pour
disperser la foule
à l'origine de ce rassemblement la
réinstauration d'un couvre feu par les
autorités face à la résurgence de cas de
kobe 19 13 personnes 13 nouvelles
personnes sont décédées hier en serbie
c'est le plus lourd bilan quotidien on
sait jusqu'ici mais la manif et sans
reproche surtout au gouvernement d'avoir
à accélérer le déconfinement et d'avoir
maintenu des élections législatives et
des interviews nous nous sommes réunis
ici pour protester parce que notre bon
président a levé l'état d'urgence à
cause des élections et maintenant il
veut à nouveau l'imposer alors nous
protestons nous sommes ici aujourd'hui
parce que notre gouvernement s est pour
la deuxième fois de nous confiner
[Musique]
d'imposer une quarantaine dont il est le
seul responsable car il a commis des
erreurs
[Musique]
ils ont entraîné l'augmentation du
nombre de patients atteints de corona
virus
[Musique]